now if you enjoy what we do here at
spectator tv why not take out a
subscription
to the spectator magazine it's the
fastest growing current affairs
publication in europe and within its
pages and
on our website you can read all your
favorite spectator
tv contributors we'll even throw in a 20
pound
amazon gift voucher all for free if you
sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk tv offer or just google spectator
tv
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
12 pounds
plus a free 20 pound amazon voucher
do the arithmetic it's a no-brainer
[Music]
now as the world ventures back into some
kind of normality at least some parts
of the world vaccine passports have been
seen as the way forward by some
not so in the united states where
president biden has ruled them out at
least on a federal level
well to discuss this and what else is
happening in america i'm joined now by
professor
lawrence gosten from georgetown
university
in washington dc he runs the who's
center
on national and global health law uh
professor gosselin thank you for joining
us on
spectator tv before we get into the
vaccine passports
could you give us just an overview of
where america now is
with the pandemic well you know there's
good news and bad
um i think for the next uh
four to six weeks we're in a perilous
position
um because we've got you know enormous
pandemic fatigue governors are
starting up businesses and restaurants
people aren't wearing masks and we have
um
you know particularly prevalent
variants particularly the one that was
originally found in the uk
which is causing surges in in certain
parts of the united states so we are in
a perilous position and say in the next
month but our vaccination campaign is
going extraordinarily well
and i think most forecasts are that
by this summer i'm certainly by the
autumn
we are going to be pulling our way out
of this
so i think it's going to be slow and
steady
and then ultimately i think there'll be
some dramatic
reductions in particularly
hospitalizations and deaths because of
the vaccine taking hold
president biden has said that by the end
of may
every american who wants a vaccine can
get one and i think that is realistic
even with the johnson and johnson pause
i saw some overnight concern in michigan
and other parts of the upper midwest
of the variant there even despite quite
a high degree of vaccination taking
place
something of a sort of a third wave it
was suggested we're not out of the woods
yet if that's happening
no we're not and that that's the fire i
was talking about
um and there are other places in the
united states i mean
really what we've learned from covid um
you know so very clearly
is is that you know it's not so much as
a wave but as a series of forest fires
and so when when one when one
pops out um in one part of the united
states
or the world um and others are feeling
you know quite good about themselves and
complacent
it always moves and you know i do expect
that to happen
you know in the next month um that the
united states as i say is going to be in
a perilous position in that month and we
really do need to be very careful in
terms of
masking and distancing before the
vaccines
really really take hold um but
eventually they will you know and i
i've actually seen this movie before um
with
other major um uh health
health threats things like smallpox
polio even
measles and other childhood vaccinations
when you have
an extraordinarily good set of vaccines
combined with high population coverage
you really can make dramatic differences
and i think
we will over the medium to longer term
what role then do you think vaccine
passports would have in britain
other parts of europe there's quite a
matter of controversy
i'd like to divide it into the official
government vaccine passports is one
possibility which
you may need to cross borders or to get
into the country or
into another country and then and this
may be particularly relevant in america
because of your highly federalized
system
50 states each of which in some ways can
go their own way
on this do you envision a situation
where either businesses
or individual states will be demanding
some proof of vaccination
before saying you get into a restaurant
or into an office or whatever
yeah andrew you've you've actually put
your finger right on it you know there
are three possibilities you know one
is uh the federal government in the
united states
and as you said president biden has
ruled that out
and i think for political and legal
reasons
he may be right to do that although i do
have one criticism i can mention
um then there'll be state governments
which really hold
the major public health powers but most
of the action is
actually going to be at the private
sector level
and already our equal employment
opportunity commission which is a
federal agency
has said it's entirely lawful for
businesses to require
employees to show proof of vaccination
as a condition of returning to work
and major colleges and universities have
been announcing mandatory vaccinations
georgetown
just did it partly on my advice
um so i think that we are going to see
this in the private sector
let me just mention president biden's
position
um because you know i while i agree the
federal
government should not mandate it i think
it would just be a huge
backlash and challenged in the courts
um but i you know i do think
that the federal government should be
providing national scientific
uh guidance and technical assistance
to whatever state and private entity
that wishes to do it
otherwise we're going to get a patchwork
of you know
variable inconsistency just the way we
did with testing
and ventilators and masking and a whole
other other things under under the trump
administration
so i think it would be wise to provide
federal guidance but not a federal
mandate
i'm interested that you think i if i'm a
restaurant owner
and i'm allowed now to serve meals
indoors
uh that if i say but to do that i want
to see your
vaccine passport that that i won't be
litigated to hell
i mean in the most litigious country in
the world i think you've got more
lawyers in the rest of the world
put together i mean this is not a
dripping roast for lawyers
it is no matter what you know if you've
got something that's got a toxic
combination of being
highly controversial and polite and
political
um and also you've got a lot of lawyers
running around you will get
litigation um you know certainly
um i think one thing is absolutely clear
that businesses
can require proof of vaccination of
their employees
i think you know we've had federal
guidance on that it already happens
um you know with hospitals on flu at
universities with various
um uh uh vaccination requirements
at schools i think we you know we are
going to see
um these this kind of thing happening
for customers i also think it will
happen it's a little bit of a gray zone
but i don't think much i mean there's
this
you'll see signs on a lot of american
shops
you might even see them in the uk you
know no shirt
no shoes no service sure you actually
absolutely are allowed to set standards
about your hygiene and health and safety
standards for those who you serve
we already require masks you know
even in states that don't mandate masks
businesses say you know you can't shop
here or you can't dine here
unless you put on a mask same thing with
a vaccine
you know a vaccine gives you a certain
cushion of safety and i think it's in
the economic
interests of businesses
to make their employees and their
customers feel
safe and i don't think there's anything
wrong with that
you know there's this huge argument in
the united states i'm sure there is in
the uk
and i lived there for 15 years and my
wife's from the lake district
so i know it really well you know that
you know
that somehow requiring a vaccine or
proof of vaccination as a condition of
services a violation of my
autonomy or my liberty or my rights
everybody has the right to make any
decision
about their own health and safety but
they don't have the right
uh to go without a vaccine or without a
mask in a crowded place and
expose someone else to an infectious
disease that could kill them
that's not your right the biggest issue
here is equity
and fairness we have to make sure that
no one is left behind
and that everyone who wants a vaccine
can get a vaccine that's why i suggested
to georgetown
and to other universities you know don't
have a vaccine mandate unless you can
actually provide a vaccine
for anyone who doesn't have it and we
will do that
and just for clarification what you
couldn't do in america an individual
state
couldn't say you can't come into this
state unless you've got a vaccine
passport because
the the borders between states are
totally porous so they couldn't operate
in that way
i'm right in thinking well yeah i'd like
to as well but we you know
what was what was standard thought um
just as you thought andrew
became blurred during the pandemic and
so
many states put testing requirements on
coming into their states
you know when when new york had its
flare-up
um florida prevented uh new york
residents and made them show
testing uh requirements uh and then when
florida
flared up new york did and it went on
and on you know most states did that in
one form or another
but normally what that does is say you
know unless you show me a negative test
or a negative
um uh or or that you've been vaccinated
will quarantine you when you come in um
but you know it's
technically you're absolutely right as a
constitutional matter you
states are not allowed to impede travel
from one state to another that's a
federal responsibility
you sounded that although there may be
some rough times uh
in the the spring and summer months
ahead
that you sounded quite optimistic about
america's position overall
as we approached the end of this year
did did i pick that up correctly
you did you know and i'm and and those
who followed
my what i've said publicly um
i i've always been um you know very
um dour and pessimistic about this
and you know you know when it when it
after it arose in wuhan and and came to
europe and the u.s
i said this would take about two years
before we came out of it
just historically that's what pandemics
are like they have
two year cycles and we're in a period of
of crop
quite advanced science and people
thought that i was being
awfully um pessimistic and i've been
pessimistic throughout but uh
one thing i do know that in the uk
europe
the united states for some reason
we have the virus has been just too much
for us to handle
we either won't or can't change our
behavior
um the way that other countries have
been able to do um but one thing we're
really good at particularly in the uk in
the u.s
is science and and vaccine development
and
deployment that's what's going to get us
out of this and so yes
um by the autumn and certainly by the
end of this year
i i think we are going to be approaching
we're not going to be
completely normal we will be approaching
more normalcy
um we'll probably still quite a while be
masking and distancing
um but i do think we'll be you know
doing the things we really want to do
you know
hug our family and and and you know
recreate and shop and
you know and and see our football games
well that's a great note to end on
[Music]
professor
[Music]
you